[Applaudissements]
il ya dans son spectacle rien à perdre
tu parles aussi différentes choses qui
te sont mariés au des sujets qui
tiennent à coeur et j'aimerais
conviennent ensemble sur certains sujets
après demain aura lieu la journée sans
transport ce sera jeudi il ya quelques
temps il y avait eu la journée sans
voiture pendant laquelle tu avais
exprimé tout mécontentement à la maire
de paris est ce que tu as eu des
nouvelles de d'anne hidalgo
non j'ai jamais une nouvelle d'anne
hidalgo voilà j'ai fait cette petite
vidéo qui était une bouteille départ
ensuite elle m'a répondu
après j'avais fait une deuxième vidéo de
réponse donc ça a été vraiment une belle
joute entre nous ça a été très
intéressant mais j'ai pas eu de
nouvelles depuis un an et la salle et
annie sur des travaux la chine c'est
vrai que traverse ap moi j'ai traversé
encore avec mon fils ce matin pour
l'amener à l'école assez extraordinaire
faut faire gaffe dans tous les sens a
taillé une voiture qui arrive là un vélo
qui arrivera alors tu essayes de sauter
pour éviter la trottinette une tape
annuel m² forme d'écho alors on parle
souvent l'héritage de johnny dans tpm
paix et je crois que vous avez un point
de vue sur la question date un point de
vue de qui magouillent le plus dans
cette affaire moi je suis persuadé alors
après ça ne tient qu'à moi
ces deux petites chinoises
développe pour le spectacle regardez
bien les images touchés dont il ya un
petit côté magouilles à chaque fois ça
n'engage que moi même il faut c'est dans
le spectacle mais alors rien à perdre ce
que comme il a plus rien à perdre ils
balancent tout un fabricant n'en démord
pas ce qu'il dirait que je suis pour
prendre le truc d'adressé vous offrant
le spectacle à n'importe quel moment ils
défoncent tout mal donc voilà de toute
façon si vous sortez des petites phrases
du spectacle comme ça la n va exactement
aussi une grosse tendance alimentaire en
ce moment c'est le véganisme on
essaierait tout le monde de devenir
vegan ça fait maintenant maintenant ça
fait beau gosse alors vous raconter des
expériences que vous avez vécu face à
des dégâts
ça s'est passé comment alors c'est pas
face à des gones c'est face à ma petite
nièce qui gagnent presque amusant
maintenant dans les familles c'est que
ces légendes 15 16 ans qui font la
morale euros pluvieux sur l'écologie sur
la façon dont vous fait et moi je les
raconte est souvent mais j'étais en
train de faire d eux et elle m'a dit
t'as pas honte de manger des foetus mais
alors j c'est pas des foetus et des
indices est pareil et je lui dis non
c'est pas pareil je pense pas qu'un
médecin quand il fait un avortement
n'attend que son jus d'orange ses
mouillettes
[Applaudissements]
musée dans la famille parce qu'elle
agace forcément et derrière j'ai tricoté
tout un sketch autour des vegan voilà
mes fesses et c'est pour rire des
défunts société aurait rien à perdre
je crois aussi que vous n'êtes pas fan
des qatari puisque vous leur reprochez
exactement qatari maintenant je je je
parle juste des quêtes
ja c'est très difficile contexte non je
je je je je parle du du réchauffement
climatique voilà ce que je parle
beaucoup du climat aussi je parle du
réchauffement climatique
est ce que j'ai vu une tare porte a
expliqué que d'ici une cinquantaine
d'années dans certains pays il aura plus
cher que le pétrole gîtes les qatari
pour être mal barré qui ont fait leur
vendre le psg pour dimitri d'evian qui
[Rires]
est très près de le battre il est même
chose sur les avec mon neveu un des
jeunes là c'est une traite de criminel
de masse est moins drôle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas si vous savez et mettez pmp
est très regardée en prison d'ailleurs
je ferai une interview en prison là
prochainement la voilà dans les
prochains jours en pour un journal d'une
prison ça y est c'est en train d'être
bouquet parce que c'est vrai qu'on est
extrêmement regardez et vous même ça
vous arrive parfois de jouer en prison
il ya une vanne que vous avez fait c'est
avec très bien marché sauf que vous avez
eu un spectateur particulier en fait
ouais je ça c'est vrai alors c'est
vraiment très contextuel parce que comme
je parle beaucoup de faits divers dans
mes spectacles je parle d'un fait divers
en particulier et j'ai compris qu'il y
en avait qui il était dans la salle en
fait
et du coup le problème et c'est pour ça
que je le fais plus trop c'est quand tu
as des suspects a qui sont à seniors sur
déchets partie je sais pas si tu
imagines tu es en train de faire un jeu
par un sketch sur guy georges dossiers
et tout d'un coup tu as geek et dans le
fond qui fait coucou d'un coup tu dis tu
dis c'est pas lui en l'occurrence mais
je suis pas sûr que ce soit encore de
l'humour disait l'autre peut pas rire de
tout et n'importe qui et là on tombe
donc en réalité quand tu joues en prison
il faut jouer les spectacles et n'est
plus les plus ouvert possible tu peux
pas les sur des choix durs en prison
c'est pas pour c'est déjà trop dur pour
eux mais le truc le plus drôle qui
mettra en prison
et ça c'est réel c'est que tu as tes
réflexes de spectacle quand tu joues pas
ce que tu voudras un public quel qu'il
soit et je joue le spectacle et je crois
que c'est angoulême suffit spectacle en
disant détenus surtout si le spectacle
n'a plus parlé autour de vous tout de
suite
enfin dans quelques temps
[Rires]